我又来晒背了喔姐妹们，
我最近迷上了钩针，
迷上了织毛衣，
但是到目前为止还没有任何的成品，
不过我现在刷抖音，
基本上10个视频出来的话，
差不多有3个半在教我怎么勾，
呃，
各种各样的花呀，
帽子呀，
小开衫儿啊，
小马甲啊什么的，
教我织毛衣，
关键是我发现一个现在。
就是你一旦喜欢这个事儿，
好奇这个事儿了之后，
你就会发现一个新大陆，
因为好多男生也喜欢，
真的，
而且是风靡全球好多国外的，
就是我，
我看到有视频里显示说去看个球赛啊什么的，
在球场上那个观众台就开始织袜子，
织各种各样的勾，
各种各样的工艺品了，
嗯，
其实很解压，
就如果说你也是啊，
有的时候挺无聊的，
或者说天天刷抖音，
脑子闲不下来的，
其实可以去试一下手工，
可以让你的脑子其实是休息，
进入一种心流状态，
是很，
就是好像一个小时，
哎，
一眨眼就过去了，
那个感觉挺好。
另外我还想说什么来着。
哦，
我想晚上在卷卷的那个账号直播回答问题，
因为卷卷不是要回家过年了吗？
就是，
呃，
让家里人看看他在这儿工作，
能不能涨点粉，
就是如果你们喜欢卷卷的话，
晚上大概7点钟或者说7点半8点钟在卷卷那个账号开播来连麦好不好？
谢谢大家啊，
不强求啊，
就是你喜欢他，
你可以多关注他，
多支持他啊。
嗯，
不是说龙飞姐推荐谁，
好像是说龙飞姐把我的粉丝就卖给了谁，
不存在的，
我们一直是这样的态度，
人和人是要讲缘分的，
嗯，
你喜欢这个年轻人，
觉得他也挺不容易的，
也在打拼，
也在为自己的事业梦想，
而且你觉得他工作态度又很好，
你想要支持他，
你就可以关注他，
好吧，
那我们就晚上见，
嗯。